all right now I promise I'm not going to
do this every single day but it's just
too delightful not to briefly talk about
it on Tucker Carlson's latest
replacement second night filling in for
the now fired Tucker Carlson on Fox News
Lawrence Jones again just made a
complete and total fool out of himself
yesterday we talked about it and I said
hey you know what guys this guy may not
be ready for prime time he just doesn't
really seem to have what it takes to put
it very likely uh he was on again
yesterday and it's confused word salad
after confused word salad from Lawrence
Jones
it's I almost am feeling a little bad
for him like isn't it so obvious he's
nowhere even remotely close to ready to
do this he had a Democrat I guess he's
usually called Democratic strategist
Julian Epstein on
and
I mean he tries to make some point and
it's just so confusing it's it's really
a trumpian word salad listen to this
immigration policy the Democrats say
that that this is a race issue when I I
I I just can't help but look at history
when it came for black Americans that
came across the border unwillingly it's
a three constitutional amendment and an
entire War to get black Americans the
right of average Day American
citizens so why do the Democrats have a
different application of the law here I
I just have no clue what he's talking
about it's something about brown people
from Mexico
being treated differently he seems to be
saying we needed civil war to end
slavery of black people
but Democrats want to treat
brown people from Mexico different I I
just don't even know what he's talking
about and this is the reaction from
people who are still watching this which
is not that many people I have to tell
you he's just not very good at this
there was another segment where he had
Lee Fang Li Fong on who's been a guest
on the program and I guess he's trying
to Lawrence Jones is trying to explain
the First Republic Bank failure which we
talked about yesterday on the
award-winning globally famous bonus show
and I don't know it he says something
about diversity and I don't even know
what he's talking about yeah so they
recruited all these minorities and their
bank's still filled so all the
minorities that bank that that there
they're screwed uh the governor
government is saying they're going to
help them but it just doesn't seem like
they solved the problem Lee thanks so
much for joining the program okay I
don't know what he means by they're
screwed I mean JPMorgan Chase bought the
bank
there's FDIC insurance it's not the
government's going to do something
special to bail bail them out they're
just there is FDIC insurance and so
their deposits are are insured visibly
confused throughout the entire hour I
don't think Lawrence Jones is going to
be the eventual replacement to Tucker
Carlson but listen I could be wrong we
will have to wait and see one of our
sponsors is short form short form makes
the world's best guides to non-fiction
books and not only does short form
Summarize each non-fiction book itself
into key points that you can cover in
just a few minutes they have all sorts
of interactive exercises to help you
apply the ideas to what you've read to
retain more the guide to each book also
includes intellectual insights comparing
and contrasting the book to other
prominent books about the same topic so
that you can contextualize the book and
understand the controversies and the
disagreements they also have books
across every non-fiction genre from
economics and politics to science and
health I was recently checking out James
clear's Atomic habits on short form of
course they have the guide but they also
have highlights they also include other
similar books about habits and
developing a routine with differences
and similarities super super useful and
a lot more than just a summary of the
book there are new guides and articles
released every week and short form is
giving my audience a free trial plus 25
off a subscription which is a fifty
dollar value so for the price of a book
per month you get access to thousands go
to shortform.com packman the link is
down below